welcome back i'm here with fellow craft
lovers sophia bush and we're going to
learn some diy crafts from front of the
show and upcycling expert sarah t that's
right
all of your crafts are easy to do
apparently easier than some tasks and
with your kids we want to revamp your
rooms and only if we can i'm not kidding
i can't i don't know what's wrong with
me and if only we had someone who could
really do this and help me and bring a
child's perspective please leo help me
[Applause]
i i do say so it's my dear dear dear
friend leo kelly i love you so much nia
and
sarah we've done the show together
before yes ma'am what are we making
today well we're going to reuse some
things to make some cool stuff for our
room right leo
i like reusing too super important okay
so one thing i've noticed being a mom or
maybe not being a mom is book jackets on
your kids books right they come off they
get ripped but i like to keep the book
jacket we don't want to throw it away so
all you need for this is a container
from around your house it could be like
protein canister something from the
kitchen you take the lid you take all
the labels off clean it up you take the
lid cut a hole
x-acto knife but you be careful with
those kid fingers and then everyone in
front of you guys have a book jacket you
want to open up your book jacket and
take a little bit of double-sided tape
and we're going to start on our end that
has uh not your main picture on it and
we're going to just put that little bit
of double-sided tape on the inside
piece then what you're going to do is
you're going to start with that piece
and we're going to wrap it around our
container and then you just grab another
little piece of double-sided tape you
guys is super easy and you just put that
right on your last piece
just like that you got it leo good job
drew you got it and there you go you got
a little themed
piggy bank we put tissues in it right
you got it that's perfect okay so up
next we're gonna do some tassels so i
love a good tassel wall um i like to
string them on a string and hang them on
the wall i think it adds a really fun
pop of color i like in front of our
table right here we have beautiful
tassels hanging and these are made out
of t-shirts y'all all you have to do is
thrift some teas or your old tees you
want to cut strips so this one that
we're going to be doing is about seven
feet long and so you want to take your
your long strip you kind of stretch it
out take your book and take your long
stretched out stringy piece of t-shirt
and we're going to start with that the
bottom of the string right at the bottom
of the book and then you're just going
to wrap it around guys that's it
just wrap you got it leo there you go
that's all you do you come around and
you wrap now remember the the bigger the
book the longer the tassel the thick the
more times you wrap it the thicker the
tassel is going to be so it's really and
you could customize these right leo
didn't you say your brother's in a
batman you could make a black and yellow
one so once you come around then what
you're going to do is you're going to
take this little string you've got one
little extra string you're going to come
up over the top of the book like this
and you're just going to tie that off
that's going to hold all of your pieces
in place you got it okay so then once
you get it tied like that check it out
yeah right
you got it
i'm in the process yeah just tie it in a
knot just like that how did you come up
with the idea to make those beautiful
mushroom ornaments
those are so pretty so someone on tick
tock did it my friend britt saw it thank
you she made some i was obsessed and
then
we started making them over the holiday
and i kid you not i lost like four
nights of my life i was just at the
kitchen table
making mushrooms and my fiance was like
are you okay i was like yeah i'm great
this is amazing i love everything that's
happening here and yet like instagram is
shutting you down and i want to purchase
one so no lost time in my opinion i made
it i love a good ornament yeah so you
make it out and then you slide it off
yeah just slide it off and that's it
then you end up getting
something that looks like this so we all
in front of all of us we already have
one that's pre-wrapped okay so pick up
your other one so what you do is you get
another piece of t-shirt and you wrap it
around to make an accent color and then
y'all you take your scissors we've got
some extra scissors here and you cut the
bottom you want to cut the bottom and
just trim it up trim it up however you
want and it kind of reminds me of fry
guys do you know what fry guys are
where were those guys from mcdonald's
the little fry guys all right guys the
the old mascot yeah that's what they
remind me of fry guys
okay be careful with scissors i know
what happened to mine
no drew that's good well this is the one
where you got the big crosstalk no you
pick up the big
there we go
all right sarah this is this is my point
though it's well in all fairness you
didn't wrap we didn't give you a long
enough piece to make that one for sake
of tv this is why i appreciate you and
what you do because this is what i would
have done and this is what you do i
think it's so yours you're very
attractive and i really do love this
garland that would make an amazing
decoration in a room absolutely it sure
would and you know what else you can do
with these what you could put them on
tents
right you could tie these on your tent
yeah like it like a tent ornament yeah
if you go like on designer website
that's they're there and then they
charge you an arm and a leg for it
exactly i guess that's the whole diy
people selling mushroom ornaments on
etsy or charging a real armor let me
tell you i love it
thank you guys so much
[Music]